hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll and i wanted to start today's
episode with a story i was on the
internet and i noticed on twitter a link
to a very interesting paper in nature it
was sort of a psychology study but an
interdisciplinary group of people
carrying it out and the study was
basically the following they would give
subjects a little grid on a computer
where there were some blank spaces and
some colored in spaces
and they asked the subjects to alter the
pattern of squares to make the image
they were looking at symmetric in some
well-defined way
so you could either add more squares to
the image to make it look symmetric or
you could remove squares you could click
on squares and have them disappear to
make it look symmetric and the human
brain says the study has this feature
that it is much more eager
to add extra squares than to remove them
this turns out to be a more general
feature the author's claim that if we
have some design problem or some puzzle
in front of us we instantly move to
adding stuff
subtractive change taking things away is
a little bit more alien to us and so you
can think about why that is the
neuroscience of that the evolution of
why we evolved that way and so forth so
i thought that would be a fun topic for
the mindscape podcast a little bit
different but interdisciplinary and
interesting so the lead author or the
leader of the lab that performed the
study was laidy klotz
looked him up on google right and to my
dismay when you type in lighty klotz
into google what appears is the name of
a professional soccer player not a
professor of engineering at the
university of virginia i'm like ah
that's not what i'm looking for and then
i realized further googling it is the
same guy laidy klotz was a professional
soccer player
later got his phd in architectural
engineering and is now a professor at
the university of virginia and carries
out these really interesting
interdisciplinary studies involving
neuroscientists and psychologists design
people and engineering people so
he agreed to come on the podcast and and
we had a lot of fun in this episode and
one of the reasons why it's fun is
there are like i said these questions of
cognitive neuroscience evolutionary
biology why did we evolve this way
there's also questions of engineering
and design right given this tendency of
human beings to like to add things
rather than to subtract does that offer
us new hints to maybe improve our design
principles by looking a little bit more
subtracting things
and finally it's almost a self-help
self-improvement kind of thing you know
can you get through your life better if
you take more seriously the option of
getting rid of things i know that marie
kondo already patented this idea and
lighty brings her up uh but what is the
science behind that you know why do we
feel happier getting rid of things
rather than our usual tendency which is
to just add them on lighty does have a
recent book on this called subtract the
untapped science of less where you can
learn about both the neuroscience
psychology and what it means for design
engineering and our everyday lives so
fun conversation
both serious but also fun in the sense
of ranging over a lot of different cool
ideas with that let's go
[Music]
welcome to the mindscape podcast thanks
sean it's great to be here
i have to start you know i always try to
come up with some useful way to start
the conversation and sometimes the
person i'm talking to has already
figured out the perfect way so you've
written a book and in the book and
elsewhere you tell this wonderful story
of playing legos with your son that
basically reveals the whole point of
what we're going to be talking about
here today so like i can do no better
than to ask you to relate the lego story
all right great my son will be happy uh
he's getting yeah he's getting his word
out all around the world so
i was he was three at the time and um
as i just was spent a lot of time
playing legos with him and i'd always
been interested in kind of how we design
i'm an engineer by training um
and i you know
enjoy behavioral science too um and
interested in the like the thought
processes behind our design so i was
playing legos with my son you know
and we had this bridge that we were
trying to build basically and the
problem we had was that one of the
columns was shorter than the other
column so the bridge wasn't level and i
went to fix this problem as any good
well-trained engineer would i turned
around behind me to grab a block to add
to the shorter column and by the time i
turned back around my three-year-old had
removed a block from the longer column
and so
again i'd i'd long been interested in
this idea of kind of like minimalist
design and you know how can we be more
sustainable on our planet but never
really boiled it down to the to
something that just like happened
literally that i could hold in my hand
this model of legos and um
what my son showed me in that moment
ended up being pretty close to what the
research revealed after tens of
thousands of hours of studying the
phenomenon is that yeah as humans our
first instinct when we're trying to
make something better is to think okay
what can we add and then oftentimes we
move on and don't don't even consider
subtracting
so number one it must be intimidating to
be a three-year-old uh designing lego
structures with your father who is a
professional engineering professor
uh but number two so you you he's uh
he's not intimidated at all not
intimidated all right i would have been
intimidated uh but the other thing is
you know you were already prime you said
you know in some sense you've been
thinking about
ways that we can build and engineer
things in subtractive ways or you know
more sustainable ways and yet even you
fell for the impulse to you know stick
the extra thing in there so do you think
this is a completely natural human thing
i mean that's what the research says
after
after after doing it and yeah and that
was um you know myself but also i took
ezra's those was my son's name i took
his lego replica around to people and i
would give it to my graduate students
and say okay solve this bridge and they
would add and then you know one of my
the
co-authors on the paper we ended up
producing about the research gabe adams
i i took it to her and i mean she's a
genius plus i had been having all these
conversations with her about what i
thought was
this same idea
which is like taking away or minimalist
design
and and she added and then when when she
yeah after she added i told her what
ezra had done and she said oh oh oh so
what you're thinking is why don't we
subtract as a way to make things better
and that make things better is ends up
being really a key part of it um because
that that was the it seems like a simple
distinction but that's what makes it
different from a whole bunch of other
reasons why we don't subtract before we
get into the details of the uh research
that you actually did on this beyond uh
working with ezra i mean do you think
that there
let's ask a nature versus nurture
question i mean if your three-year-old
is better at it than you are does that
tell us that it's culture that is
inculcating this idea we should add
things rather than subtract them yeah
that's the one downside of the of the
ezra story is um it kind of leads you to
think that oh this is a nature versus
nurture thing and we have absolutely no
evidence that that's the case and in
fact i would
posit that ezra's even worse than me at
adding um it's just that he plays a ton
of legos and this was the one chance
where we where i stumbled across him
subtracting um so so we haven't
explicitly studied it in kids um but we
have in our experiments you know looked
at the different um
you know segmented people by groups and
things like that to see oh are you know
younger people better is there any
difference between male and female or
you know other ways that might like
indicate uh a difference that would
suggest it was cultural as opposed to
just kind of an eight and um haven't
found any evidence of that again i think
that but that is high on our list of
kind of next step studies um it wouldn't
surprise me if there was you know slight
variation and as a educator i'm really
interested in you know
what are we doing in our education that
might be kind of
you know propping up this bias or you
know what could we do to kind of help
people deal with it
but no ezra is not a master subtractor
okay yeah i was gonna decide he's
probably just a master lego builder
that's a perfectly uh sensible
response there but but before we get
into the experiment which is really what
i want to get into but
let's you know let's pretend that we're
following
the scientific method we were taught in
high school right and so we're supposed
to formulate a hypothesis before doing
the experiment so
what is the most rigorous way you can
state the hypothesis you know when you
have literally a set of legos and you're
either putting blocks in or taking them
away i see the difference between
subtracting and adding is there a more
general idea of what that means what is
the hypothesis we're trying to test here
yeah there is a more general idea and
it's it spans across physical objects
ideas and situations so basically when
when we're trying to change things
whether they're ideas objects or
situations from how they are
to how we want them to be
um
are we likely to overlook subtraction
basically or do we yeah um do we think
of adding before we think of subtracting
but i guess is the maybe this is an
obvious answer but is there do we always
know the difference between adding and
subtracting it's always clear what
counts as adding and what counts as
subtracting yeah that's a good
yeah that's amazing uh question um
in the experiments yes i mean in the
real world no
right i mean it's impossible to tell if
you know i'm you know where as i'm
taking a
an item off of my calendar am i really
looking at that as a subtraction or am i
looking that is like you know freeing up
space to be able to add something but in
our
experiments we were able to that's the
beauty of experiments um you know for
example my favorite experiment we
basically well we created this grid on a
computer screen where people could add
and subtract and
you know we did a couple of things one
we uh you know we told them explicitly
what was adding and what was what was
subtracting and then after the fact
asked them like did you add or did you
subtract so we're confirming there that
yes you know this thing that that we're
counting as adding
they are thinking of as adding um
so yeah so that's a good question though
because i mean a lot of the examples i
use in the book like um
are more kind of real world design so uh
and you know in real world design what i
use mile in designing the vietnam
veterans memorial and it's this cut into
the mall in washington dc and it's this
beautiful monumental architecture and
you're like well
you know it looks i can argue that it's
subtractive compared to the washington
monument but um what what was maya lin
really thinking and i use it in the book
because we have record of her thinking
of it as a subtraction but most things
we don't actually have what the person
was thinking yeah so you mentioned the
grid you mentioned the experiment i mean
you're
an engineer by profession but this is
clearly some kind of psychology
cognitive science experiment so uh
there's you're giving your subjects a
computer and a 10 by 10 grid with some
white squares and green squares and
you're asking them to add or subtract i
mean so what exactly were they asked to
do and
is it clear that they're assuming that a
white square is a nothingness an absence
an emptiness and a green square is a
thing is that how they're
conceptualizing it
right um
yes so we um
you know i should deal with i'm an
engineer first because i am indeed an
engineer and i've dabbled in behavioral
science basically one of the things that
i like about behavioral science and one
of the things that's happening with
behavioral science is people are
starting to apply it right and and use
it to make things better you know so
like nudging and
um and other ways to use behavioral
science to make change i mean that's a
very engineering way of looking at the
world it's you know we're we've got this
science okay now what can we do with it
to try to make the world a better place
or you know meet certain objectives so
i'd always been approaching it from that
perspective and was able to kind of like
take some
you know really well-known nudges for
example and apply them in engineering
and i could study that by myself and but
these these grids you know as you're
listening to me talk you're not just
listening to an engineer you're
listening to the combined work of an
engineer plus three behavioral science
co-authors who worked with me on the
paper and gabe adams i mentioned before
but also ben converse and andy hales all
three of them are
trained in psychology um and you know
really helped us you know i wouldn't be
able to do this research without them
and um
so
the grids uh the the most convincing
paradigm in my mind we ended up with um
a number of different paradigms that we
use showing people kind of adding more
than they subtracted but all of them
were subject to this criticism that you
could make about the legos right and the
lego criticism would be well that's just
because that's what we do with legos
right we've been taught to
build with legos we've grown up building
with legos this is like what we assume
we're supposed to do with legos and then
you could also argue well this only
applies to legos
and so we made this grid example
thinking okay nobody's done these
specific grid activities before and
there's no kind of inherent value in the
grids right there's no value to blocks
on a computer screen
and
and we set these things up so that the
grid pattern basically was broken into
four quadrants um
and what we
what we did was put extraneous marks in
one of the quadrants um and then told
people to make the pattern symmetrical
from left to right and top to bottom so
we had different patterns but in all of
the patterns there are a couple basic
options one would be to subtract the
extraneous marks by clicking on them
and the other would be to add marks to
all three corners so it you know and the
other nice thing about this way of doing
it
is that it's it's just better to
subtract in this case i mean the bridge
example you can make the argument that
of
adding and subtracting either or it
doesn't matter but in this case we said
do it in the fewest clicks possible so
subtracting was the right answer not
just one answer um
and we before people did the studies
we'd give them
opportunity to practice and say okay you
can add green blocks to the area or you
can subtract
you could subtract these marks from the
area and we'd have them practice so that
they knew how to do it and they were
practice adding and subtracting and then
in that case we asked them after the
fact you know did you add or subtract as
one of the checks afterwards and they um
kind of
responded that they were doing the thing
that we thought they were doing
does that make sense so they knew they
they had conceptualized the idea of
subtracting blocks they would they
weren't tricking them by not even
letting them think about that
no no yeah
sustainability is a hot button topic but
it's more than recycling bottles and
ditching plastic it's about seeing
choices through a wider lens that
extends not just from paper and plastic
but all the way to kitty litter that's
why i love sweet scoop they led the
charge as the first renewable kitty
litter and now they're upping their
commitment to sustainability by becoming
plastic neutral in partnership with
plastic bank it relies on one
sustainably sourced ingredient namely
wheat wheat has naturally occurring
starches and enzymes that actively break
things down
and it works the cats love it it's low
dust load tracking easy to dispose of
and unlike clay litter sweet scoop is a
hundred percent biodegradable so if
you're stuck between litter that works
and litter that's pet and planet
friendly sweet scoop doesn't make you
choose go to sweetscoop.com to get a 5
off coupon and find a retailer near you
now to spell it correctly that's
s-w-h-e-a-t
scoop.com as in s wheat scoop.com
and so
it's interesting the the comparison of
that with the lego example because i i'm
trying to think of trying to play the
devil's advocate and think of
alternative explanations here
with the legos um
i i think there's it plausibly
an implicit idea that if there are
blocks already there they're there for
some purpose even if you did it even if
they're you know you made it up but
there's some structural idea so we can't
just take things away without hurting
someone else's plans for what's going to
happen right but i suppose that this is
part of the point of the computer grid
is that there's no purpose whatsoever
it's just a design
yeah that's great it's um
uh there's a an awesome youtube video
that nature made about our paper and the
most liked comment is a version of of
what you've uh what you've just said
which is and um so
and it but it also brings up a really
important
distinction here i mean our paper showed
that
all else being equal people don't even
think of subtraction um
but
the
the thing that so we ruled out the thing
that you just described where okay
there's some like inherent value to the
stuff that's there or or somebody
thought about this right it's like okay
somebody's smarter than me thought about
building this bridge and
who am i to take it away without you
know kind of putting a whole bunch of
thought into it and that's really
important for subtracting in the real
world but it happens after
you've thought about it right so what we
found is that people don't even think
about it but then after you do think
about it as an option then you could
have this deliberative process where
it's like okay i thought of this option
but i'm not choosing it because
um for any number of reasons and one of
those one very good reason would be i'm
not going to subtract because somebody
has put more thought into adding this
thing and who am i to take it away
so you've ruled out that hypothesis that
that even if it that's clearly not going
on people are still more reluctant to
subtract and and you know i think there
were several paradigms that we used i
mean we used we had a grid example we
had um
miniature golf uh
the maybe another
describing another way that we used the
grids might help explain how we how we
ruled this out you know so first and
foremost the grids don't have any
inherent value right there is clearly
just a random pattern and
so it's hard to think that somebody
would look at that and say oh the person
who arranged this random pattern thought
it was really important and therefore
we're not going to take away
but
also
evidence that people weren't even
thinking about this option but
recognized it as superior after they
thought of it um we we had them do
repetitions on the grids so give them a
number of
grid patterns a series and
this is similar to what was happening
with ezra it's like okay you did this a
bunch of times and you know if on the
third or fourth time they did it they
did recognize subtraction um and did
actually stumble upon it and choose it
and then you'd ask them afterwards well
what's the best option which and they're
like well obviously the subtractive one
it was fewer clicks um and so you know
what that shows is that it wasn't that
they were
choosing against it for some reason
whether that be they you know don't like
taking things away because of loss
aversion or whether they don't like
taking things away because they feel
like somebody's thought about this
that rules that out pretty clearly when
the people don't choose it when they
don't think of it but then do choose it
when it's brought to mind in some way
yeah no that that makes perfect sense
and the other thing that i thought was
very clever in your experimental design
was that you also
uh
tested them when they were being
distracted by some other task at the
same time and if i remember the effect
was even stronger is that right exactly
so i mean the theory there would be that
um if if this is something that's like a
heuristic or like just an in a way of
thinking you know we we're more likely
to
you know go to those default
mental settings when we're under
load when we're under cognitive load and
we don't have much time to think and so
this is funny too because you know
we knew that that was a way that we
could test it and there here we are you
know for people thinking who've been
thinking about subtraction for a long
time and and all we could think about
was how do we
um
how do we add cognitive load how do we
add kind of
well we could also manipulate this by
removing some cognitive load anyway um
and one of the ways you add cognitive
load is um having
numbers scrolling across the bottom of
the
grid experiment for example while people
are doing the the study and you say okay
every time a five comes by press f on
your keyboard and so you can do both of
those things at the same time but you're
a little bit distracted and when people
were
more distracted they were even more
likely to go to that adding
adding default to not think of
subtracting so that was evidence that
it's like okay this is some kind of
metal shortcut that we're using um
because you know when we add this
cognitive load we're even more likely to
use it it's also a very you know kind of
speaks to a more problematic thing as
you get out into the real world right
because as we add ideas and concepts and
thoughts what's that doing that's adding
cognitive load which is making us even
less likely to
take away
and so it's kind of this reinforcing
loop that works against subtraction yeah
i mean so it does seem that there's you
got a lot of evidence that uh we
favor the idea of adding new things in
problem solving in general rather than
taking them away um is there anything we
can say about
how the brain works that makes that
happen uh either the level of
neurons and so forth or at least at the
level of sort of other psychological
strategies that we use to get through
the day
not at the level of neurons i mean i
think the best thing that we can say is
that uh
when we
um the adding is the first thing that
comes to mind basically but this is a
heuristic that we're using for whatever
reason i mean it may have been very
helpful in the past and it kind of lines
up with
query theory if you're familiar with
that i mean it it is what it sounds like
basically like we consider options in an
order in the order that we consider
options matter right and so the way this
becomes harmful is we consider adding
first and then we've
satisfied we're like okay i've solved my
problem by adding and you move on
without even considering subtraction so
the best kind of why
we have or the best what's going on is
that like we're considering adding first
when we are encountered with these
when we encounter these situations that
we want to try to
make better by
by changing them in some way could you
actually uh elaborate on the notion of
satisficing which i which is a terrible
terrible word
i'm coming across more and more often
but it's certainly a very useful concept
in how we make decisions
yeah i mean so herbert simon coined this
term and i mean i love herbert simon as
a scholar i mean he's uh he's kind of a
precursor to kahneman and taversky
basically you know he was
his big contribution one of his big
contributions he actually made it a lot
in a lot of areas but
one that he won a nobel prize for was
showing that you know people aren't
rational um in this specific way and
that they satisfies i mean you just
don't have
infinite time to optimize every
situation right so when i'm buying you
know tomato sauce at the supermarket i'm
not sitting there saying you know doing
this complex optimization problem
between like price sodium content and uh
i don't know taste i'm i'm just like
okay this one is less than five dollars
it doesn't have a ton of salt and you
know so i satisfied and move on and i'm
able to spend more thought on like what
kind of pasta i want to buy
and we do this all the time and it makes
perfect sense you don't you know you
can't spend all your time on trivial
decisions um so
and
but it is a terrible word satisficing
and i had to use it over and over in the
book because simon coined it and i
remember my neuroscientist neighbor who
was a reader of the book he's like is ah
this is horrible jargon can you get rid
of this like you know i tried to get rid
of most of the jargon but this is like
it means something i can't just i we
need to recoin it but um
yeah so satisficing is this portmanteau
of you know satisfactory and suffice and
um
you know it's since been shown in all
kinds of
decision processes and it just you know
makes sense is something that we would
do and
this tendency to satisfy combined with
adding first
can lead us to not you know kind of
optimize if subtraction was it was an
option um and i guess the last thing i
would add on satisficing is
you know what's really great about simon
and even you know kahneman and tversky i
mean they always point out that there's
a
often a helpful reason for these biases
right these deviations from rationality
like
as a general thing
they're there for they've evolved for a
reason and they're they're mostly
helpful but there can also be situations
in which they
become harmful so satisficing mostly
good but in a case where
you know the right answer is not the
first thing that comes to mind then
satisficing is gonna be problematic
i think it's actually an
underappreciated fact of life how finite
we are in our ability to like think of
all the possible ways to do things maybe
herbert simon
knew about this very well and i'm just
not familiar enough with his work but uh
you know i talked to stephen wolfram
recently on the podcast and he
emphasizes what he calls the
computational boundedness
of uh finite structures such as himself
such as ourselves i i talked to uh carl
fristen with his free energy principle
and you know we try to be good bayesian
updaters but really we sort of
approximate it in some nice way and so
the idea i think the idea that you're
adding here that i'm not sure i ever
thought of or stumbled across is that
we have like a list of strategies that
will
implicitly apply to different problems
and it's an ordered list and you know
it's not random and sort of if we have
some goal of satisficing then whichever
strategy gets us there first is the one
we'll use even if it's not the best one
is that a fair way to say it
yeah that's a fair way to say it um
and eric johnson is has done more work
than anybody in this area and uh elky
weber so they're uh elky's at princeton
eric's at columbia eric has a book
coming out called the elements of choice
that is is all about this a popular book
that's all about this um
and but yeah you summarized it exactly
correctly and it it is incredibly
important i would add too that i mean
my guess is that this kind of
overconfidence in our own like numerical
abilities or you know our our you know
optimization of things is especially
prevalent among researchers right i mean
that that's going to be a blind spot
yeah yeah to us and engineers too right
it's like we've been doing these
calculations our whole life and getting
the right answer and you know we kind of
think that that applies to
every situation that we encounter in
life which you know is not the case
right the other bit of jargon uh that
maybe comes from condom and tversky that
you use is loss aversion
um we we for whatever reason we are more
hurt by losing a little than we are
uh made happier by gaining a little bit
i'm not sure i'm explaining it correctly
so maybe but maybe this has some
relationship with uh subtraction versus
addition
yeah perfect explanation um
and there is a relationship it's they're
our
nature well
it gets back to that kind of
clarification that gabe made and gets
back to ezra's bridge actually it's like
to make things better what we're
interested in is taking things away to
make things better and in that case less
is not a loss you know what kahneman and
tversky were looking at was like these
cases where you lose something where it
is harmful in some way and you overweigh
that
relative to
to gaining something and so that that's
a very good reason we might
um
a danger as it relates to subtracting i
think is when we subtract something if
we interpret it mistakenly as a loss and
and focus on the things that are have
been kind of taken away then we can um
it can fall into this kind of thinking
and and waiting that we do related to
loss of version where if you if you kind
of mentally categorize this thing as a
loss you're going to
be more emotionally damaged by losing it
when in fact the subtraction was
actually to make things better and um
we'll go from simon and connorman and
tversky to marie kondo here right so
she's the the decluttering
right and she tells us to take
stuff away um but what does she do
you know the whole focus is on the the
clean room that you're gonna have the
tidy space it's not about the physical
things that you're taking away because
you know it is a barrier to taking away
if you're sitting there thinking oh well
i really liked this
you know my t-shirt that i never wore um
and i'm gonna feel bad when i lose that
t-shirt and sure you're going to feel a
little bad when you lose that t-shirt
but overall you're going to feel really
good when you have this you know
streamlined
room and so what she does is kind of
steers us around loss of version by you
know keeping us focused on
the game that we're going to have by
subtracting the the good thing that
we're going to have by subtracting and i
think we can you know
you can take that and think about how
you would apply it in all kinds of
subtractions whether it's you know
physical stuff or whether it's your you
know your your to-do list or the ideas
that are in your head head i mean you
know taking things away
sure you know
there is some emotional attachment to
the thing that you're taking away but
the the bigger picture goal is this kind
of end state that is in fact better it's
not a loss it's always a little bit
dangerous i think to try to apply
evolutionary explanations to some of
these psychological features but maybe
it's worth trying in this case
anyway i mean is there a story we can
tell ideally a testable story but at
least some kind of story about why we
would have evolved or developed maybe
and i i guess the distinction being
maybe it's not through
adaptation but maybe just some reason
why the brain chose to prioritize our
strategies to put subtraction way after
addition yeah it's dangerous but it's
fun to think about this
and i mean
so chapter two of the book is kind of i
thought of as like evolutionary
explanations for this and then chapter
three of the book is kind of more like
cultural evolution i'll i'll start with
the
biological ones and then you can tell me
if you want me to go into the cultural
ones but the you know obviously the
biology this this desire to acquire
stuff right i mean that's something that
you know yeah getting food allows us to
pass down our genes um and
there's uh stephanie preston does a lot
of research on this she's at university
of michigan another psychologist and i
cite her in the book a lot but
she's looked at acquisitiveness why
people like get and keep things and she
basically shows that this
acquisitiveness she has this brilliant
study that she does on a computer screen
where people are like shopping and they
keep all this useless stuff and then
they are told to like constrain their
their items to the shopping cart and
they're unable to do it um like unable
to get rid of this completely useless
thing and i mean she shows that that
basic
behavior is is continuous with you know
hoarding um but it's also like tied to
just pack rats for example i mean pack
rats they when you take away their
supply of stuff they immediately start
stockpiling it and when you first think
of that you're like well of course they
you know that's what we do when our
pantries get empty but pack rats aren't
thinking and planting
animals right they're doing this
entirely on instinct um and so
so there's that um the other kind of um
surprisingly for me uh again being you
know kind of coming at this from the
outside um
was the how
biological this desire to display
competence is um to basically show that
we can interact with our world and so
the classic example is bauer birds
building nests and so
the male power bird builds the
ceremonial nest and the female bower
birds are going around looking at the
finesse and deciding who they want to
mate with based on the nests and then
after they mate the female bowerbird
goes and builds another nest and raises
the young in that nest so the whole
point of this ceremonial nest is just to
show
that the male bowerbird was capable of
like interacting with the world and to
the extent that like
you know adding legos or adding
to do's or just showing you're busy can
kind of display this competence um
that's also kind of a biological tie-in
that would lead us to add but to be fair
um the last thing i'll say about biology
is that you know if you talk about this
just beautiful
if you're using it as a metaphor
adaptation and what's the other
selection right i mean so nature's
moving forward by adding not moving
forward nature is evolving by adding and
subtracting um and so as a metaphor uh
that is actually pretty helpful in
thinking about oh there's there's
multiple ways that we can kind of
um evolve and one is by adding to what's
there and one is by subtracting from
what's there i don't think we
necessarily need to go to bauer birds i
think there's plenty of human beings who
clearly want to show off their ability
to acquire and own things i'm just
making them just see on instagram yeah
who needs to do exactly i'm just making
an excuse for those people yeah that
it's that it's a
biological excuse
but the cultural you'll be interested in
the cultural one because this is not
something that i think gets enough yeah
it was surprisingly
clear among the anthropologists set and
historians
that at the dawn of civilization right
so when we're going from kind of
hunter-gatherer to um to farming
there was this thing
that was always there so that you know
they talk about writing um had to be
there and then like kind of organized
social structures back then it was often
religion um
and then they talked about monumental
architecture always being there i was
like i'm a civil engineer i love big
structures but i thought well this is
like a pretty lofty place for big
structures to be like one of the things
that has to be there for something to be
considered a civilization
but the theory there is that um
you know by building the body of the
civilization that's what helped build
the culture of civilization so you know
these early settlements you've got 25
hunter gatherers roaming around in a
band can only do so much but then if
they want to build some kind of
ceremonial
thing
similar to the bauer bird nest or
similar to you know some of these
pyramids or
other temples things like that then all
of a sudden the people have to
coordinate right and so the theory is
that this desire
to build
is actually what brings people together
to kind of scratch that itch
so there's that kind of cultural um
cultural thing too to the extent that
we've all evolved from those
civilizations right i mean those are the
civilizations that spread around and
then became us whether you're
western eastern interdependent
independent uh whatever
when you give to charity how much impact
will your donation actually have this
question can be hard if not impossible
to know most charities can't tell you
how your money will be used or how much
good it will accomplish if you want to
help people living in poverty and want
to make the biggest difference possible
i recommend you check out givewell
givewell has spent more than a decade
researching charitable organizations and
only recommends highest impact
evidence-based charities over 50 000
donors have used givewell to donate over
750 million dollars rigorous evidence
suggests these donations will save over
75 000 lives and improve the lives of
millions more and give well is free
givewell wants to empower as many donors
as possible to make informed decisions
about their donations they publish all
of their research on their site for free
no sign up required if you've never
donated to give wells recommended
charities before you can have your
donation matched up to a thousand
dollars before the end of august or as
long as matching funds last to claim
your match go to givewell.org pick
podcast and sean carroll's mindscape at
checkout make sure they know that you
heard about givewell from mindscape to
get your donation matched
well you're you're sparking all sorts of
things that came up in previous podcast
episodes so i hope you'll uh forgive me
for mentioning them but uh
i want to press on that a little bit we
already we already talked about sort of
the cultural aspects could it be
different in different countries you
know i did have joe henrik on the
podcast and he was emphasizing how we
westerners are a little bit different
than everybody else and i noticed that
in your book uh you quote lao tzu right
and we i recently had edward slingerland
on the podcast to talk about ancient
chinese philosophies
uh taoism and and confucianism and so
forth and how a big goal
that is common to most of those is
trying not to try sort of like living in
the moment going with the flow etc
but maybe that's just aspirational maybe
it's not the natural thing the natural
way that people behave
can you say anything about if we had
done all of your studies uh in china or
in africa or whatever do you think you
would have gotten the same answers
uh well what i can say is that we did do
studies in
japan and germany and the variation
between
the us culture like the u.s population
the u.s samples and those samples was
less than the variation within the u.s
sample
um so that's you know that's what we
found i i do it's
you know high on our list of things to
study next you know what the variation
is across cultures because i do think
that there would be some variation i
don't think you know the evidence that
we have suggests that it wouldn't turn
off this
bias but you know certainly you could
think that you know different people
would be different and and better or
worse at it um
i think uh i mean the the
you know the the latsu quote um
that gets attributed to him anyway is
that you know to gain knowledge
add things every day to gain wisdom
subtract things every day which is i
mean a beautiful quote and and ties in
nicely to how we do this in our ideas um
and
the benefits when we actually subtract
ideas um
the the kind of do-nothing approach i
see is a a third option i mean because
like this you know
subtracting is not not trying it's a
very active like hey i want to change
this thing it's a very kind of
if you're talking about it in terms of
independent versus interdependent
cultures i mean that's hazel marcus's
kind of way of categorizing them and so
the independent cultures are more like
the the westerner way of like hey i'm in
control of my own destiny i can change
the world and make it how i want it to
be and the interdependent is every you
know yin and yang everything's going
back to the way that it used to be or
everything's going back to this kind of
equilibrium
um and i think subtracting is a kind of
a very
independent
thing to do it's an action that you're
taking to try to change things um
so in that way it's kind of different
from this you know sit back and let's
just see what happens approach that you
know is is part of some of these
philosophies certainly your other guests
know way more about this than i do but
i'm just trying to offer what i know
about it from thinking about it through
this very specific lens of what it means
for our ability
to add and subtract i think that's why
it's a really
interesting question for future research
because i think there's there's reasons
to think that
there's reasons that it might go both
ways for example
where like the
um
uh allow me to explain this so the uh
one theory might be yeah but if you're a
interdependent culture so these are the
ones that are affiliated more with
eastern cultures although of course it's
never so simple as that um
you're better at seeing the big picture
right um and you need to if you're
taking the big picture back to our grids
on the computer screen right people who
can see the big picture might be able to
see okay here's something that can be
subtracted from it if you're just
looking at the blocks in isolation
you're less likely to see that this a
single subtraction could
improve
the big thing and that that would you
know that could be one reason or one
theory why maybe the these
interdependent cultures would be better
at seeing this as an option um but at
the same time i just also made a case
before where like in independent
cultures are more likely to think about
maybe how how do we like change things
from how they are to how we want them to
be which you know
that would say suggest maybe they would
be better at this um so yeah that's
that's what we know about culture it's
certainly uh
certainly a lot to learn
there still and i mean i don't know i
think the for me the punchline about
cultures is like so
you know what can you do about it right
um again it's a very engineering way of
thinking about it and i think it's it's
really useful to understand why these
things evolve differently in different
cultures but
you know giving people the
recommendation that you should have been
born in
uh some culture that was better at
thinking about subtracting is not it's
not very practical advice um not very
actionable yeah so i mean i have been
you know pressing you on all these
questions about biology and evolution
that i know and psychology that i know
are not what you're mostly trained to do
let me give you at least the opportunity
to elaborate on um something you said
over emails while we were discussing
this you hinted at this uh entropy based
discussion that you wanted to put in the
book but your editor wouldn't let you so
you've come to the right podcast to give
an entropy based explanation of anything
at all so is this what was the entropy
based discussion was it a reported
explanation for why we like to uh add
things rather than subtract yeah and i i
think the reason i put it in the email
is i wanted to hear your thoughts on it
and i think the editor rightfully
subtracted it out of the book i mean
i didn't have any evidence for it and uh
and i feel actually less well trained to
talk about entropy than i do about like
loss aversion for example um not that
they're on the same level as a
scientific concept but anyway that the
the shortest logical entropy explanation
that i could think of is
one reason that we might have these
develop these thinking heuristics over
time is that we're just surrounded by a
world that
it reminds us of them or advantages them
right like it's an advantage to them so
if you know over time it's been really
good to su
to add you know when we added uh added
more shelter that allowed us to pass
down our genes more we added more food
that allowed us to pass down our genes
more
um or you know help that culture thrive
we
we
you know the more times we do it the
more likely we are to continue doing it
and then
in addition the more we're surrounded by
these
examples of adding right so you're
walking around the city all around you
are things that people have added
something that somebody took away like
in my book i used the example of the
embarcadero freeway in san francisco
amazing subtraction created this
beautiful waterfront i visited that
waterfront as a civil engineer and
didn't know for
until five years after i had visited
that there used to be a highway there
right so the the reminder of subtraction
is gone and so we walk around in this
world where there's all these constant
reminders of adding and to the extent
that entropy as i understand it is this
kind of like kind of where constant
adding of complexity um
then maybe it's not just the um kind of
human built world where we're seeing all
these reminders of adding but it's the
whole natural world where we're seeing
all these reminders of adding which
could then
lead us to
think that this is you know just give us
more reminders that this is a way of
making change
does that make sense
and yeah poke holes in it and you know
actually i think my the
the concept does make sense to me i'm
not sure if entropy is the right word to
attach to it and again i don't have any
more evidence for the concept than you
do but if i'm if i would were to sort of
say it back um
there's an idea
that
i actually broached this idea in a solo
podcast i did a while ago about the
meaning of life uh the idea being that
there's sort of there's sort of a
natural way things would go if we didn't
do anything right like if we didn't
influence the world in any way at all
um and that's that can be fine uh but
the idea of a life that is meaningful is
sort of one that has
worked to improve or make the world
better in a way that it wouldn't have if
you just let everything play out as it
naturally would have so in some sense
the value that we bring to and get from
our lives is
inheres in the difference between
what happens because we're here and what
would have happened if we weren't here
and so i i it seems very plausible to me
as you just said that the most obvious
signs of those kinds of
uh meaningful changes in the structure
of the world are adding things to it
right i mean probably there are other
meaningful ways you could subtract
things to it but if you're just looking
for
why is it more obvious to add things
that does seem to fit into that sort of
uh way of thinking
yeah is that that's a very independent
way of oh yeah thinking about meaning
right yeah i mean that's really how i am
i mean
i think to the like when you're
you know
donors leaving their
100 million dollars to a university for
a building right it's like this is the
thing that lives on after you um and
it's a very visible artifact of your
positive influence on the world um so
yeah that's uh
that's interesting um but yeah that's
the closest nobody's ever left a lot of
money to a university to tear down a
building i don't think
it wouldn't have to be as much money you
don't you'd only have to give about 10
and you could make uh
well and that and that is an
entrepreneur it's easier to tear the
building down than to build the building
because you're increasing entropy when
you're tearing the building down in a
very manifest way
uh so that's why i'm not sure exactly
how the entropy fits into the story like
in some sense it's the struggle against
entropy uh that we recognize as
achieving something or you've built
something that wouldn't have just
happened in the natural state of things
i see okay
yeah so maybe um i'm glad i didn't write
it in the book
but it does bring me to the next big big
subject here that i want to talk about
you know sort of to
uh move on beyond the psychological
explanations for why we think this way
to the ramifications of this way of
thinking for what you do in the world of
engineering and design
and sustainability and so forth i mean
there's some
uh
you know in the world of all the things
that can happen or we can build or that
we can do there's far too many options
to possibly contemplate and the
implication of your work is we more
naturally contemplating adding things
and putting things on but
the point you're making is when you have
a complicated system it can very
often maybe equally often be the case
that you can improve things by
subtracting and that's something we are
not as immediately noticing right um and
this is what drew me to
behavioral science in the first place uh
there's this great quote that you'll
appreciate about um
it's that behavioral science or
complexity science becomes like a
gateway into behavioral science
or vice versa but anyway the um
as a person who is interested in the
built environment and then interested in
sustainability both you know kind of
social sustainability with equity and
things like that but also just you know
just i'll talk about it in terms of
climate change um that sort of makes it
a little more tangible and uh
the the challenge is not
well obviously we need new technologies
and things that can help with climate
change but for the most part we know how
to do this better we know how to make
net zero energy buildings um the
challenge is like how do we how do we
get this into practice and that's what
got me to behavioral science in the
first place like yeah there's you know
of course keep advancing the technology
but what about the technology in our
brains as designers and also as people
kind of
using the designs that that would help
here
and
this
this bias that we've been talking about
this heuristic that we you know kind of
just go right to adding
it seems very aligned with
you know the the problems of
sustainability if you think about the
pro one way that these problems get
framed as like planetary tipping points
right in the
article in
i think it was in science not nature but
the article in science talking about
where we are with these planetary
tipping points and a number of them
we're like past them uh we're we're too
late the point of
and and it's so then the uh the option
is so obviously what we need to subtract
we need to like get back down below but
you know we're still approaching these
problems with this mindset of like okay
what can we add to this situation um
again that's
zooming
you know going back down a level like
thinking about it in terms of climate
change i mean recently we've been
thinking a lot more and putting into
practice ways of you know kind of
removing co2 from the atmosphere whether
trees or or what what have you but for a
really long time i mean we've scientists
have known that climate change is a
thing and and
most of our efforts have been at
reducing our adding right slowing our
rate of adding co2 to the atmosphere and
it's only when we've
exceeded like we're literally you know
scientists are saying it's safe to have
350 parts per million we're
up over 420 parts per million and so the
up that part of the solution clearly
needs to be to subtract some of the co2
and yet you know we've really been
delayed and thinking about that as part
of the solution and
you mentioned subtracting in complex
systems and climate
you know and co2 in particular is an
example of how subtracting can
you know all else being equal maybe even
be a better option you know so of course
we need to think about all the ways that
we can address climate change and i'm
not you know advocating for
a single
response because that's not what we need
we need to be exploring everything but
if you're
you know some of these geo-engineering
proposals it's like okay we're going to
put mirrors up into space and reflect
the sun's rays and so it's like or you
know fill the oceans with iron
and
again i'm not qualified to evaluate any
one of these things as a good or bad but
what is sure about those options is that
we're adding more stuff to this really
complex system that we screwed up
without even trying to screw up in the
first place right and so yeah
yes adding these things might help with
climate change but they are also adding
more kind of
tension and more inner relationships
that are unpredictable and that we you
know we aren't really sure what's going
to happen whereas if you take out the
co2 yeah that's still an unpredictable
thing it's you know we're intervening in
this really complex system but we do
know what a world looks like with less
co2 it was like the world you know
when we had less co2 so it's a more kind
of um
we have a little more idea of what that
how that system would behave than we do
when we like continuously add things to
a system and uh
the
you know tying that same concept into
back to behavioral science and um you
know so climate obviously this is a big
physical system there's this another
eminent uh kind of the founding father
of social psychology called kurt lewin
and he um
he was
he was like herbert simon and that he he
was very applied in the way he studied
things lewin was uh he was from poland
he moved to germany he had to come to
the united states because hitler was
rising to power in germany and his whole
like approach to social science was like
how do we use this to make the world a
better place how do we use this to solve
social problems and um
so he would look at these systems and
try to understand
you know behavior from the system's
perspective his advance was like this
isn't just about
you know sean or lydia
and the thoughts that are in their head
it's also a lot about like what's going
on around them that's causing them to
behave in a certain way and so he
thought of behavior as like forces and a
field which are things that he's
borrowing from physics right so there
are forces that are acting on you and
there can be forces that are working
towards the behavior that you want and
there can be forces that are working
against the behavior that you want and
he said that the good way to change
if you want to change behavior there's
one good way and one bad way is that the
bad way was to add incentives or add
forces that are kind of working in the
direction that you want it to go and the
the good way is to remove the forces
that are working against you and it's
the same as climate like if you remove
the forces that are working against you
you're relieving tension
in the system um
which is better than if you add an
incentive it's like yes you're helping
yourself get to the
make yourself more likely to get to the
behavior that you want but you're um
you're also increasing the tension
should you not achieve that behavior
that you want so i think about this in
terms of back to ezra my son when when
we're trying to get him to not watch the
ipad
after dinner
i can say oh well if you don't watch the
ipad you can have a cookie and that
might work i've added an incentive it's
making him more likely to do the
behavior he might happily eat the cookie
and not have the ipad or
but it can also backfire where he's like
okay now he still wants to watch the
ipad and he's super frustrated because
he's not getting a cookie
and
the the kind of removing the barrier is
you know putting the ipad out of sight
or telling him that it ran out of
batteries right and then it's not even
an option and you've kind of so anyway
the this is where you know both in the
example of this big physical system with
climate and also in the example of like
a social system where you're trying to
change
individual behavior um
where taking away removing
can be
sometimes even a better option than than
adding and again it's not you know i'm
agnostic on adding versus subtracting i
don't think
we should only subtract of course but
it's like this is where this tendency
that we've found to overlook subtraction
is really problematic when it these are
maybe the better options
if you happen to be listening to this
ezra don't worry these are just thought
experiments we would never tell you that
the ipad has run out of battery if it
hadn't really done that
but yeah
yeah
um
the the example of climate is is
interesting but it's also a little bit
different i mean obviously the climate
is a very complex system but in some
sense it's
almost too cheap of an example because
we kind of know
what we're doing wrong we're putting too
much co2 and other greenhouse gases into
the atmosphere and subtracting them
would be good but there are other
examples uh you talk about traffic flows
for example
where
it's just what much less obvious what to
do and even without trying to people
remove a
highway from a busy city
traffic flow pattern and the traffic
improves even though you have taken away
an option and and maybe that has to do
with how we think and satisfication
or whatever it's called and uh but you
know
i'm looking for the lessons that we
might have when dealing with complex
systems like traffic flows the economy
the internet or whatever where
is there some
theme that we tend to add things but
maybe we should think of the beneficial
effects of subtracting them away let me
tell the traffic story and um and the
science behind that and i think you'll
listen those will be smart enough to
distill
um so there's this my editor
speaking of editors um there's this
thing called braises paradox in math and
it's the the finding that you know the
best example
is is uh is highways but it also applies
to these other complex systems that you
talked about like networks where you
take away a part of the system and the
system performs better and that's
considered a paradox and the fact that
that's considered a paradox is
perfect evidence of the fact that we
don't think of subtracting as a way to
make things better right because the
reason it's called a paradox and i'm
holding up quotes is like
because it's so unthinkable that taking
away could actually make something
better and the reason that it works
the reason that it happens so you think
of a highway
and you take out a highway from the
middle of the city well how could that
possibly help
traffic capacity and it's because
and it does actually tie back to
satisfying where
people
the the system wasn't operating at a
optimal equilibrium in the first place
right it's just people had you know
found their way to get about the city
and it's settled settled into this
equilibrium that was basically working
for people and when you take out the
part of the highway it's basically like
shaking the whole thing up and it
settles back down into some other
equilibrium and this other equilibrium
because you weren't at optimal to begin
with this other equilibrium could be
could be worse you know traffic could
get worse or it could be better
and it's happened a lot that traffic
ends up being better
and people just find different ways to
get around the city and these highway
removal projects that are done for you
know removing the highway
on the embarcadero in san francisco was
not to make traffic better it was to
open up that waterfront and people just
assumed it was going to make traffic
worse but and that was an acceptable
cost but and then the fact that it
doesn't make traffic worse becomes this
you know pleasant surprise but that's
happened a lot i mean in highway removal
there's a famous one in in seoul korea
where where it happened and it's you
know happens more and more and now it's
not unexpected that the
the highway removal actually improves
this um
you know removing a component of the
system actually improves the system's
overall performance there's an awesome
quote uh that tying back into the brace
paradox thing there's this guy kurt
kafka who is a fascinating scientist he
was kind of um
one of the earlier like gestalt
psychologists um
and these were these scholars in germany
who were basically taking a complex
systems approach to human behavior and
uh kafka was married to
he was married four times to two
different to the same two women
so figure that out but uh but he had the
he's he's the originator of this quote
the whole is greater than the sum of its
parts
um that like sports announcers use but
that's not the actual quote the quote he
said was the whole is something else
than the sum of its parts and it's
actually because
it and he's and he he could get so mad
when people would misquote him and
there's another great quote where he's
like this is not a principle of addition
so he's fighting the same like kind of
tendency to think that adding is the
only way that you know
the hole is greater the no the hole is
something else than the sum of its parts
um
well but that that brings us up to sort
of where i wanted to
um wind things up with the
down-to-earth human side of this kind of
stuff like there's one thing when we're
designing uh a traffic flow pattern for
a city but most of us don't do that
maybe you do that i'm not i'm not quite
sure but uh most of us just try to get
through our lives and you already
mentioned marie kondo and her strategy
of removing things that do not spark joy
um
i can kind of predict what you're going
to say but to what extent can we human
beings improve things in our everyday
lives just by at least contemplating
subtracting things rather than adding
them i think immensely and i know that
some of these
some of these biases you know kahneman
will talk about his biases you know just
knowing about him doesn't help you be
any better at them but a lot of his
biases are related to
you know thinking about something but
then not choosing it um and certainly
he's got a whole catalog that so they're
not all just that but
what we're talking about here is the
situation where we don't even think of
something so to the extent that you can
help yourself think of this option that
you're not otherwise considering and
then just put it through all the same
filters that you're already using i
think it just opens up a whole new
world of of opportunities and i mean
that's
what i hope to do with the book is you
know kind of
show people this thing that's happening
show them ways that people overcome it
and hopefully rearrange your mental
furniture just a slight bit so that you
consider this option that we've
otherwise neglected so i think it i mean
i think it can make your life
a little bit better um and
and i don't think it's
impossible to do i mean i think just by
listening to this podcast you're gonna
have a
you know
find yourself seeing more of these
options and then when you you know
then the trick i think is to kind of
help give yourself reminders of how
these subtractions have made your life
better right because we talk about the
subtracting from the waterfront and now
the the highway is not visible as
evidence of this thing that you did and
it's the same if you like stop doing
something on your calendar right so if
you take away this activity that you've
been doing weekly for the last 10 years
of your life
pretty soon it's out of sight and out of
mind and you don't have this reminder
that you subtract it and you have this
to thank for subtracting to thank for
this beautiful
free time um
and so you know somehow reminding
ourselves
that subtracting is to thank for this so
the calendar example i know one of um
ben one of the other co-authors his his
wife uh she will use when she takes
something away she will like leave a
block on her calendar of like this time
brought to you by such and such a
subtraction and so here's this visible
evidence of
this way that she
you know achieved change um in a
and it serves as a reminder to subtract
on on future things but um so that
that's my hope is that you know it can't
be bad to be thinking of more of our
options especially an option
as basic as this one as long as they
don't subtract their podcast listening
from their weekly calendar that would be
that would be terrible we don't want
anyone to do that don't take that advice
but but it is
kind of subtract all your other
yeah subtraction
of course sorry other podcasts
um
but you know the the information that
we're inundated with is clearly uh a
fertile arena for imagining subtracting
things right the
our twitter feeds our emails every day
our screen time and and so forth
it's kind of obvious in some sense that
there's too much of it there and the
choice
to be made is what to pay attention to
and you know part of that choice is what
not to pay attention to right exactly
yeah i mean this is an area that we're
working on this has been really helpful
for me i mean i used to run on a
treadmill while watching the news while
listening to a podcast
um
and there was no time
running used to be the time where i
would you know kind of synthesize stuff
and digest the stuff that i had taken in
the rest of the time and again it's it's
add and subtract here you can't just
not
take information in but
thinking deliberately about okay what do
i want to take in when do i not want to
be taking in information so that i can
be thinking about stuff that i know that
i may no longer want to be
no longer want to believe i mean i think
that you know as a scholar subtracting
as a person who writes books and does
research subtracting in our ideas is the
most powerful
form of of subtracting it's like what do
we what do we no longer believe that we
used to believe and that's a really
powerful thing for self-improvement but
also for
scientific revolutions right i mean so
many of these scientific revolutions
required
forgetting or not forgetting but
stop thinking the old way of doing
things i don't know um
are you do you remember this like kind
of trend towards misconceptions as an
educator um so it's like okay
students come in with common
misconceptions about physics um and
you know physics chemistry and and it's
it's a worthy thought right it's like
okay we're going to identify the things
that people are coming to us you know
thinking that are incorrect so that we
can kind of start from a clean slate and
there was this whole like
theme of educational research in that
area identifying these common
misconceptions how to break them down
and and subtract them
and then eventually that
we just gave up on that because it
wasn't how people actually did things it
was so hard to subtract these
misconceptions that we just said okay we
need to figure out a way to kind of
adapt
what students are bringing in and kind
of like allow them to you know massage
these misconceptions a little bit and
then attach the new knowledge onto that
so it's really hard to do in our ideas
but also really
really powerful when we are able to do
it well i think isn't it even worse like
my impression is that when you talk to
people about misconceptions and you
dwell on them trying to remove them they
end up coming away with even stronger
versions of the misconceptions than they
came in with because you spent all your
time talking about them
that's true yeah you're right um
the most helpful thing i found uh
about
trying to help with this problem was the
uh was using analogies and it's it's
it seems like a really unscientific
thing but you know like there's all
these records nancy nursesian studies
this it's like the history of scientific
religion revolutions but also like a
thomas kunian approach but uh
looking at the thoughts that were going
on inside the revolutionaries heads and
it was surprising how many of them used
analogies and uh
the reason analogy helps is because
you're basically
taking the new idea and attaching it to
something else that's already in the
person's head
and then
when you do that
those two things added together can kind
of overpower the the misconception but
if you just come at it with the the new
idea and there's no analogy to tie it to
it doesn't overpower the
misconception but anyway you're exactly
right though that um and i hadn't
thought of it that you know the more you
kind of dwell on it it's like yeah
you're kind of drawing attention to the
one thing that if you just kind of
smooth it over and just focused on the
right ideas you might do better and
maybe that's why the learning scholars
stopped dwelling on it well i don't i
don't recall if you actually mention
this example in your book when you talk
about scientific progress um
uh albert einstein in special relativity
is the perfect example of what you're
talking about i'm not sure if uh no
you're gonna have to explain it to me
you thought of this particular example
yeah i mean it's a fascinating story and
i'm not the a super good historian about
this stuff but we give albert einstein
credit for the theory of relativity
there was the special theory of
relativity in 1905
speed of light is the maximum speed and
there's no
preferred reference frames etc and then
the general theory of relativity uh 10
years later where he says space time is
curved and clearly general relativity
was his baby like that that came out of
the brain of albert einstein and he gets
all the credit and deserves all the
credit but special relativity which was
the first one
was really much more of a team effort
there were a lot of people who thought
along those lines around that time and
what he really did
was put the final finishing touches on
it with this very dramatic conceptual
move of saying
everyone is talking about the ether
right this idea of something that
spreads throughout all space and defines
uh the standard of rest with respect to
things move and so forth and they went
to incredibly elaborate uh
mechanic
machinations to make sure that the
standard of rest of the ether could be
completely unobservable there's no way
of noticing it and really all einstein
did was say okay then we don't need the
ether
just get rid of it and we can have all
the success that we have and people you
know it took a little while people said
yeah actually that's right it was a
largely subtractive move that made
everything much simpler
that's awesome yeah no if i had that
example i would have used it in the book
but i didn't unfortunately yeah that's
the downside of doing these awesome
conversations after writing the book is
you come up with things that oh man i
wish i included that that's brilliant
it's yeah no i know it's very terrible
though there could be a sequel and yeah
i'm sure i presume that
here's the last question
you're a writer now you got a book uh
out there that people can buy called
subtract um
how much
were you conscious while writing of the
fact that i'm telling people to subtract
things i better make sure to subtract
things from my writing and from my book
it was horrible it was like yeah i mean
because i'm quoting from strunk and
white in there right amid needless words
and it's you know as you know as a
writer yourself i mean you
it's hard and um you know i think that i
did a you know
90 job in terms of like creating what i
could do in terms of getting rid of
extraneous stuff but i'm sure people can
go through the book and find stories
that they wish weren't in there or um or
words that they wish weren't in there so
i was i was very conscious of it um i
tried to
deal with i also talk about editors in
the book so one of the things it's hard
to subtract from your own stuff right so
this this tendency that you mentioned at
the at the start where it's like okay
when we
you know it's one thing when you're
subtracting a bridge that someone else
did but when it's your own bridge that
becomes even harder um and uh so that's
where the editors can come in and be
helpful and so i think that there's
there's about 40 000 words that didn't
see the light of day that i wrote um and
and probably very good
still some more but i was very conscious
of it you know yeah once you go out
telling people how to behave uh you're
gonna be open to that criticism all the
time but all yeah look all we can do is
try to be better that that's uh that's
the lesson for all of us so lady klotz
thanks so much for being on the
mindscape podcast this was fun yes thank
you sean i had a lot of fun too
[Music]
you